se nos pide ordenar las longitudes de
los lados de un triángulo de menor a
mayor aquí tenemos las tres longitudes y
podemos como tú puedes ver usar esta
herramienta para ordenarlos de alguna
manera y si observas el triángulo puedes
ver que se nos dieron las medidas de los
tres ángulos internos del triángulo pero
no nos dicen cuánto mide cada lado
entonces bueno como se supone que
debemos ordenarlos de mayor a menor si
no se nos está dando la medida de cada
lado bueno vamos vamos a averiguarlo
vamos a trabajar en esto lo que debes
saber es que el orden de las medidas de
los lados del triángulo está relacionado
con el orden de la medida del ángulo
opuesto al lado que quieres encontrar lo
que quieres medir a qué me refiero con
esto bueno vamos a pensar en los tres
ángulos del triángulo pensemos en este
este que mide 57 grados es el menor de
los tres ángulos quiere decir que el
lado que es abierto por este ángulo lo
puedes pensar como el vértice opuesto al
lado el lado que es abierto por este
ángulo
será el lado más corto del triángulo así
que ve será el lado con menor longitud
el siguiente ángulo con mayor medida que
57 grados es el de 58 grados por lo que
el lado a será el lado con longitud
mayor que b pero menor que se es decir
será el del medio no es ni el más largo
ni el más corto y por último este ángulo
de 65 grados este ángulo se abre hacia
el lado c es decir el lado opuesto al
ángulo s por lo que ese será el lado más
largo y bueno para entender por qué las
cosas son así
imagina lo siguiente imagina un mundo en
el que al ángulo de 65 grados lo haces
más grande supongamos que haces a este
ángulo de 65 grados más grande moviendo
estos dos puntos hacia afuera qué
pasaría si haces eso bueno pues si haces
eso el lado se se haría más grande
y como los ángulos internos de un
triángulo deben sumar 180 si este si
este ángulo de 65 grados crece en medida
mide más de 65 grados entonces estos
estos dos ángulos tendrán que medir
menos de lo que miden para que juntos
suman 180
análogamente si tomaras al ángulo
digamos a este ángulo de 58 grados y lo
haces más pequeño que pasaría en ese
caso observa que entonces el lado a se
haría más pequeño y no estoy dando una
prueba formal de esto pero la intuición
es que el orden de los ángulos nos dará
el orden de los lados respecto al tamaño
el lado más corto tendrá opuesto al
ángulo más pequeño y el lado más largo
tendrá opuesto al ángulo más grande
podemos de hecho comprobar la respuesta
la comprobamos
no tenemos bien ahora hagamos otro
ejercicio pero este será opuesto al otro
entonces bueno en este queremos ordenar
los ángulos del triángulo de menor a
mayor y se nos dan las medidas de los
lados ahora no te espantes es la misma
idea ajá el ángulo más pequeño será
opuesto al lado más corto este es el
lado más corto de longitud 7.2 y el
ángulo opuesto a este lado es el ángulo
a entonces a es el ángulo más chico el
lado que sigue en longitud es el lado
que mide 7.3 y el ángulo opuesto a este
lado es el ángulo b entonces el orden es
y luego ve y finalmente el ángulo c es
opuesto al lado más largo por lo que se
es el ángulo más grande y ya ahí está
terminamos ordenamos los ángulos del
triángulo de menor a mayor